こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
長い間
住ませていただきましたこちらの
3億円のお家
一つ
嘘がございます
このうち
本当は
3億円ではないです
誠に申し訳ございませんでした
誠に申し訳ございません
私は
嘘を
つき視聴者の皆さんファンの皆さんを欺き
このお家を
3億円だと
3億円だと嘘をつき続け今に至ってしまい
ました
誠に申し訳ございません
このお家のお値段
正しくは
4億円です
すいません3という響きが3という響きが
あまりに良くて気づいたらこのうちの値段
このうちの総額が4億円いったにも
かかわらず長らく長らく動画のタイトルや
サムネ
映像内で3億円と1億円嘘ついてしまい
ました誠に
選手
[音楽]
嘘つきたくなかったんです皆さんに
嘘つきたくなかったんですけれども言う
タイミングがなくてだって3の方が綺麗
じゃんあと読んで仲間傷だしこれ僕の高校
の高校のバスケ部の時の背番号ではあるん
ですよって実はよう好きでけどなんかもう
3億円って言わなきゃいけない雰囲気
みたいなのがあってずっと
嘘ついて4億円を1億円詐欺って動画で
記述そして
撮影しておりました誠に申し訳ございませ
んでした
この動画以降
誠心誠意込めて事実のみを伝えるために
動画内だろうこの家の表記
全て
3億円から4億円に変更させていただき
たいと思いますご了承よろしくお願い
いたします
[音楽]
はい皆さん改めましてこんにちはよく人の
お家の家主はじめしゃちょーです何かの
動画でも言ったんですけど気づいたら
4億円いってたんですよなんかボソッと
しか言ってなくてみんなのお疲れ様です
みんなの中で朝3億円のお家なわけじゃ
ないですか俺もそう思うのもう3億円
ハウス3億円ハウス3億円のイメージが強
すぎて
改めてこういう動画を撮らないと4億円の
お家って言っちゃダメな気がしてまして
ちょっとタイミングがなかったねしばらく
4億円行ってたんですけどもう3億円のお
家というちょっと1億円鯖を読んで動画を
撮らせていただいておりましたすごいね
もう4億だよとりあえずですねでもこの
動画を持って3億円のお家はもう終了
存在しません今後はすべて統一です4億円
のお家という表記になると思いますそれを
ね改めてちゃんと動画にしないとなんか
突然でびっくりするし意味もわかんない
なっていうことでしっかりそのけじめの
変更のタイミングとしてこの動画を撮らせ
ていただいておりますただ間違いなく値段
を嘘たのは間違いないのでそこは本当に
申し訳ございませんというわけで3億円で
買ったおうち4億円になるまでのプラザの
1億円どうなっていたかをちょっとこの
動画で説明していきたいと思いますどこに
一応保険使ったんだろうって皆さん多分気
になってると思うのでちゃんとそのプラス
1億円がどこなのか説明した上であの
4億円の入れて呼んでくださいじゃ
ちょっと見ていきましょうか細かい部分と
か色々あるんですけれどももう普通にね
こういうアルソックとかの何か警備の
警備強化にもかなりお金使ったしこの扉も
丸ごと変えたんですよねこれ最初壊れてっ
て誰でも入れるようになっててそういうね
なんかセキュリティ面のお金のかけ方は
かなりやりましたねこういう照明とかも
そうですねお金かけましたしこういう
ところの照明も全部買いました
エレベーターももちろんそうエレベーター
のお金かかってますよいつも使ってる撮影
部屋のこういうめちゃくちゃ明るい照明と
かもねもう来た時にすぐお金をかけて
改造しました
ねあとソーラーパネルとかこの屋上テラス
とソーラーパネルが4億円になるもう
決め手になりましたねここはかなり
大きかった気がします
どうも
サウナスペースですねさあここもかなりお
金がかかりましたし今も実は改造しており
ます
[音楽]
シックでいい感じですね実はこここの
雨宿りとか鯛を強い時にハーフっていうの
かなこういうのつけてみちゃったりとか
あと
めっちゃかっこいいサウンドチェア買い
ましたこれ確かに40万ぐらいした気がし
ますやっぱいいサウナには良いサウナ
チェアでしょうこれめっちゃ柔らかいのよ
ほらマジで
週23では入ってますねサウナここも
かなりお金がかかった場所だと思います
はい今見せた部分はもうほんとこの家のお
金をかけた一部分に過ぎないですもっとね
全体的に例えばよなんか電気量を根本的に
増やすための工事とかインターネットの
回線を引く見えない部分のところとか今
映さなかったいろんな場所の正面とか諸々
を含めて3億円で買ってさらに1億円課金
してこの家が今4億円に至ったわけで
ございますいやー
[音楽]
1億使ったかお家ってこんなにお金かかる
のね大学時代から賃貸もうお金を払って家
を借りてきてしかなかったからこんなに
例えば何かを作りたいとかつけたいとか
改造したいとかなる時にお家ってこんなに
お金かかるんだなと思ってちょっと
びっくりしました
この家だけなのかもしれないんですけども
ちょっと規模感がね家が大きすぎてね1つ
の構図でもすごいお金がかかったりする
ことがあるなと思ってこの家に住んでまだ
2年間1年あたり5000万ずつ使って
るってことかすごいエグいですけれども
こんなね44部って言っても皆さん
嘘だと思うでしょ
嘘だと思うので今回ちゃんと経理部に
1億円どこに使ったのかしっかりと内訳を
もう証拠として提示させていただきます
これでもう皆さん信じてよくの言えて言え
ますよね
ありましたありましたとりあえずトータル
ね
修繕と回収工事費支払いが総額で
1億37万8839円となっております
ちょっと超えちゃってるねこのゲーム今
ようこ37万8839円ですまあもう現在
進行形で今も新しいコーチが進んでたりし
てるのでもうどんな増えてくのでちょっと
またあのその5億になったら伝えます
すでに上がっていくんですけどもどう打つ
だけしているか受水総修繕費に
40万7000円受水槽ってその水を
ためる部分ねあるんですよそこでまあ
40万防犯カメラ設置とかセンサーで
500万500万だよね
500万円
セキュリティ大丈夫ですからセキュリティ
ないとこの仕事成り立たないし僕も家の外
に出ることがとれないのでこれは必然的な
もう必須のお金も必要経費ですねええ
500万円か4回撮影部屋リノベーション
とガラスの種類ここですねここで大体
108万
給水ポンプの交換で188万
前回の網戸の修理ねちょっといろいろ壊れ
てた部分もあったのでそういうの直すのに
67000円空調工事に
1400何これ1400万ぐらいかかって
ますねエアコンとかやっぱ夏暑かったって
言ってたじゃん昔の動画で暑すぎて
乗り切れないって今ちゃーんとエアコン
効いて涼しいです大豆のお金ですねでも
1400万かかるのか普通の家だったらよ
普通の家というかなんか賃貸とかだったら
ねエアコンパッてつければ済むこともこの
家に関してはエアコンパッて作るの
1400万かかりますからエレベーター
832万そうですね800万ぐらいかかっ
てます1階の防犯扉に178万電化製品の
備品購入で115万
ネット整備工事まだいたい80万サウナ
2647万サウンドがやっぱり一番かかっ
てますね何もなかったところに作ったから
それはお金かかるわねでシェルター隠し
シェルター作ったのに770万配信卓備品
購入パソコンとか
置いたのに37万前庭のメンテナンス
11万高松のコンサル量なちゃんとねあの
コンサルしてもらってるんですよ
コンサルティング」って何でしょう
ちゃんとそのこうしたらどうでしょうって
いうそのプロの方この家作ってくださった
デザイナーさんと今連絡取ってまして絶対
知ってるわけじゃんこの家のことをもっと
誰よりも一番
最強なんですねこの最強のもうそもそも
この家を作ったデザイナーさんにちょっと
コンサルとか色々お願いしたりして進めて
おりますこれは必要ですね300万近く2
階の冷蔵庫とブラインド修理冷蔵庫を最近
新しくしたんですよねまあ245万
ガレージシャッター修理110万
シャッター閉まんなくなったりするんです
よトイレの回収229万トイレもね直し
ましたシェルター隠しシェルターでネット
使えるようにしましたネット追加で58番
屋上の太陽光パネル755万
太陽光パネルもお金かかるんですよつける
となると前に我が38万5000円給油機
なんかねお湯枠のすごい遅くてそれの修理
で340万インターホン全部新しくしまし
た72万2回冷蔵庫製氷機配管で
効率作れるようにしました16万浴槽等の
修理とかで66万でまあ諸々こう合わせる
と1億超えちゃったっていう感じでござい
ます
[拍手]
お疲れ様ですお疲れ様です今日も続きまし
てこのお家4億円ハウスになりましたお
疲れ様ですご苦労様でしたありがとう
ございます
[音楽]
ご苦労様っていうこっからまたスタート5
に向かってどうでした1億円使ってみた
気分
なかなかないことだよね
いやでもいろいろやりましたよねっていう
感じ
[音楽]
で
値段見たんですけどサウナが一番かかって
てねそうだね結構やっぱ大規模でやって
もうすげえのできたからそうねでもやっぱ
1億使っただけあってここのお家の
クオリティがもうバカにしたんじゃない
マジでマジですごいだってエアコンなかっ
たもんそうなんだよ本当にねやっぱ1億円
使っただけあるなっていうぐらい本当に
良くなったしもうここまで来れたのももう
本当に大地君がね
立ち会ったりしてくれてしっかり全部見て
くれたおかげで本当にありがとうござい
ます
ここからどうしようって話ですよねいやで
もこの1億円使って何だろう直すものは
直したみたいなところ結構多いじゃない
ですか空調であったり照明であったり
なんかもうまたこうサウナみたいな新たに
何かを作っていくっていう
はいもう考えてますのにはいもう考えて
ますそれはまだ発表したらもう動画の
楽しみがなくなっちゃうんでちょっとまた
ね動き出したりしたらまた紹介しますし
管理人のチャンネルでもねその様子とかも
日々出したいと思うのでそちらをぜひお
楽しみにしてください次はまた
冒険でお会いしましょうでは
[音楽]